monsieur le Président cher François
Monsieur le Commissaire européen cher
Thierry Breton chère Jean-Yves heureux
de te retrouver en tête
Mesdames et Messieurs les
vice-présidents madame la secrétaire
général au travers de toi remercier je
le dis tout de suite et Danne Caroline
et toutes les équipes tous ceux qui ont
fait la réussite une fois de plus le
Guidel Mesdames et Messieurs les élus
les parlementaires monsieur le Président
Marseille que je suis aussi heureux de
retrouver il change de place
tu bouges
chers Hervé je suis très heureux de te
retrouver là puis de retrouver
évidemment mes collègues
Sarah Philippe évidemment Jean-Noël a
Guidel ici des noms jour en premier
remercier tous les salariés du siège des
bénévoles mais aussi les prestataires un
mot de Lady qui ont fait une fois de
plus la Russie de Guidel et qui font que
Guidel paraît toujours aussi simple et
naturel ce qui n'est pas le cas dans
l'organisation toujours mais en tout cas
pour ceux qui participent qui vivent qui
travaillent qui réfléchissent ça paraît
toujours aussi simple et naturel et
c'est sans doute un atout de notre
famille au sens le plus étymologique du
terme de ne pas nous laisser emporter
par la force des habitudes le poids des
acquis en un mot de ne jamais oublier
dont on d'où on vient on apprend pas
parfois
oser pas souvent pas grand chose
de ces victoires l'on apprend souvent
plus des épreuves et des difficultés et
ces épreuves et ses difficultés nous en
avons fait une force une manière d'être
aussi que nous nous reconnaît souvent
dans la manière d'exercer nos
responsabilités et dans la manière
d'être dans l'espace politique d'une
certaine façon l'occasion de rendre
hommage au groupe politique que tu
présides Jean-Paul et à ceux qui
travaillent aussi au Sénat il y a
quelque chose de particulier parce que
nous savons ce que c'est que la force
des épreuves et aussi le temple le
sentiment qu'il faut avoir d'humilité
dans les temps qui sont devant nous
c'est pourquoi je voudrais
en nom de tous remercier encore pour
cette douzième édition de Guidel notre
profonde reconnaissance à ceux qui font
la réussite ils sont Guidel au fond
c'est plus qu'un rendez-vous annuel
c'est un peu le tour du cadran qui
chaque année vient réaffirmer notre
solidité individuelle et collective
notre solidarité sans faille notre
capacité à continuer de penser librement
et avec une constance qui n'existe je le
crois dans aucune autre famille
politique c'est la capacité aussi à
entendre des points de vue on l'a vu ces
trois jours des points de vue différents
et en faire tous au fin d'entre soi au
taux satisfait Guidel c'est cela qui
fait nos valeurs et qui fait qu'une
valeur sont si actuelle ce sont les
valeurs que l'on porte et les défis que
l'on essaye et les débats que l'on
essaie de porter qui sont au cœur de
notre siècle
guidès est aussi un repère un point fixe
qui s'est tenu contre vents et marée
c'est le cœur de la mer et ses
profondeurs plus que l'écume et le bruit
des choses et c'est aussi devenu le
point de convergence pour tous ceux qui
se reconnaissent dans les valeurs du
centre dans les valeurs de l'humanisme
et quel que soit le chemin qu'ils aient
pu emprunter auparavant c'est un peu
cette maison décrite en son temps pardon
de le citer mais parfois on peut citer
des gens extérieurs par Léon Blum
lorsqu'il évoquait les épreuves de sa
propre famille politique et qui disait
nous sommes convaincus jusqu'au fond de
nous-mêmes que pendant que vous irez
courir l'aventure il faut quelqu'un qui
reste garder la maison ou peut-être vous
viendrez ou reviendrez un jour et nous
étions quelques-uns à penser les choses
ainsi alors que nous étions peu nombreux
autour de François et Marielle à tenir
la maison
et je me réjouis de voir Guidel
s'enrichir chaque année de nouveaux
visages ou de visages plus familiers
c'est bien la démonstration la plus
évidente que ce lieu est la maison de
cette famille de pensée et vous me
permettrez de dire simplement merci à
celui qui a gardé cette maison avec une
détermination une fois durait certain
sans pareil c'est bien François qu'on
l'on doit cela c'est lui qui avait au
sort de la maison dont nous allons
[Applaudissements]
de la maison dont nous fêterons les 100
ans l'an prochain et qui menaçaient
parfois de s'effondrer ses fondations
chères François se sont les
sympathisants les militants que je salue
que la constance et la cohérence de
notre de ce qui ouvre politique
réunissent ce sont les cadres je pense
en particulier au président des
mouvements départementaux à leur
délégués ce sont les membres du Conseil
national ce sont nos parlementaires qui
s'expriment à l'Assemblée au Sénat au
Parlement européen chers amis on a
longtemps dit et parfois reproché et on
a longtemps dit que c'était parfois une
aventure personnelle cela confondait
sans doute la responsabilité propre au
leader et au leadership
et oublier que c'était avant tout une
démarche collective portée par le
collectif et avec une visée collective
et cher François je voudrais juste
ajouter ce matin et je veux en témoigner
que ce combat tu l'as toujours mené avec
un sens une exigence une éthique et une
morale civique dont je peux attester et
auquel tu n'as jamais failli et je veux
le dire et je veux le dire
[Applaudissements]
et je peux le dire et je veux le dire
moi qui suis dans cette maison depuis
plus de 25 ans comme quelques autres y
compris au premier rang
et qui et puis le qui peut le dire avec
la plus grande vigueur et avec la plus
grande sérénité et c'est justice de le
dire devant vous tous ce matin chers
amis comme élu local depuis 1995 comme
secrétaire général du Mouvement
Démocrate comme ministre et comme
premier vice-président j'ai vu notre
famille politique tenir son rang avec
solidité je le disais et je la vois
aujourd'hui porter des valeurs des
propositions une posture j'y insiste qui
ne peuvent être plus être actuels au
regard des mots dont souffre nos
sociétés démocratiques et je peux le
dire comme ministre de l'Agriculture et
de la souveraineté alimentaire parce que
les enjeux auxquels je suis confronté
nous sommes confrontés dans ce domaine
au quotidien dise quelque chose des
mouvements à l'oeuvre dans notre société
alors je vais en citer quelques un
premier de ces mots première de ces
difficultés au premier de ces mouvements
la remise en cause constante des paroles
autrefois considérées comme légitime ce
qu'il faut autorité ou ceux qui
faisaient autorité que ce soit les
responsables publics les scientifiques
les journalistes les intellectuels de
notre temps
il me semble que nous sommes dans un
moment où au profit de cela on ni la
science et la raison la plus élémentaire
on trie ce que dit la science on tord
les faits jusqu'à ce que n'y soit plus
que des instruments des instruments
tronqués au service des croyances ou des
idéologies à refuser on refuse la raison
au profit de la seule passion et nous
l'avons vécu cette forme de remise en
cause de manière évidente ces dernières
années et je ne citerai qu'un exemple
lors de la crise sanitaire et nous le
vivons au quotidiennement aujourd'hui il
y a une course je le dis grave une
course vers le néant dans ses attitudes
qui fait que le doute devient nihilisme
et l'hypothèse devient dogme
avec un deuxième mouvement de ne pas
avoir ou de ne jamais devoir devant
l'opinion portée de responsabilités en
fait ce refus a accepté les faits se
doute donc d'une irresponsabilité assez
confortable
celle qui aboutit au fait que personne
n'est inquiété jugé coupable de ces
paroles ou même de ses actes
l'irresponsabilité totale la plus
absolue et personne ne vient demander
des comptes
aux tenant du brexit au scientifiques
qui à longueur de tribune on peut dire
un certain nombre de choses devant les
médias et personne ne vient dire quel
est votre responsabilité dans ce monde
d'irresponsable nous avons besoin nous
de réaffirmer le principe de
responsabilité à pousser sur la science
et appuyer sur les faits sinon nous
courons à notre perte deuxième de ces
mots l'injonction de l'immédiateté et de
la simplification à l'excès qui tend à
faire de nous des soldats de fortune
sommet de choisir le camp du pour ou du
contre du blanc ou du noir du OUI ou du
nom et qui interdit ou au moins empêche
la nuance à laquelle nous sommes
pourtant tant attachés et nous nous
aurions au-delà d'y être attachés tant
besoin la dictature de l'immédiateté
c'est l'inverse de ce que nous pensons
mais c'est surtout une manière qui
empêche ou interdit de penser le temps
long et j'invite à regarder ce que font
nos grands voisins les grands empires si
je peux dire qui eux sortent du temps de
l'immédiateté et pense le temps long
François dit souvent ça parfois on pense
au mois ou à l'année quand eux pense à
la décennie au siècle
et cette tyrannie l'immédiatet elle est
un empêchement pour nos démocraties
aujourd'hui et à est une faiblesse pour
nos démocratie parce que alors qu'elles
étaient un élément de stabilité de
capacité à penser le temps long dans le
temps qu'on vienne qui viennent
immédiatement pousser puissamment par
les réseaux sociaux vient empêcher de
penser le temps long et nous avons
besoin de penser le temps long quand les
défis nécessitent de le faire il me
semble que je voulais le dire devant
vous troisième de ces mots
l'individualisme à tout craint qui fait
passer le jeu avant le nous qui confie
nos refus de la diversité de la
différence sauf quand elle s'applique à
soi alors que nous savons tant besoin de
bienveillance
et de compréhension mutuelle je suis
chaque jour fasciné de voir comment
notre société qui ponne pour bon nombre
pour bon nombre de domaines la tolérance
pour soit la refuse aux autres et la
refuse surtout et cela même refus
catégorique du compromis à l'affirmation
exacerbé pardon des identités tout est
motif désormais
identitarisme la religion le territoire
les idées le mode de vie l'alimentation
le sport
il me semble que tout ça est un appel à
la division et pas un appel à la
tolérance et nous avons besoin d'être
ceux qui portons la tolérance et je suis
fasciné que nous ayons dans un pays au
pays des Lumières que nous enseignons à
disserter pour savoir si nous sommes
pour ou contre le barbecue
il me semble que ça n'est pas à la
hauteur des enjeux que nous pourrions
estimer il me semble qu'il faut penser
d'abord notre monde dans sa transition
avec tolérance tout cela mène à un
dialogue public qui n'est plus conçu
comme un espace d'échange et de
citoyenneté permettant de partager des
objectifs des contraintes et donc à
cheminer vers la recherche d'un
compromis mais comme une opportunité
d'imposer ses vues et finalement à
s'affirmer soi-même et cette violence
verbale dans l'affirmation de soi cette
violence du débat pourrait écraser
l'autre elle a inexorablement une issue
et nous le voyons chaque jour à l'heure
elle débouche sur la violence physique
et donc je mets en garde aussi sur ceux
qui par la violence des mots permettent
suscite invite
à la violence physique quatrième de ces
mots
[Applaudissements]
le quatrième de ces mots et dernier de
ces mots le catastrophisme déclinisme le
collapsologie
qui mène au discours les plus fous et à
une idée qui ne peut nous être
insupportable pour les humanismes que
nous sommes c'est qu'au fond l'idée que
l'homme devrait disparaître parce qu'il
serait le problème et non la solution à
nos problèmes ça serait ça l'horizon et
ça n'est pas notre horizon parce que
nous sommes des humanistes
et c'est une société de la peur et une
société de la peur qui se construit
c'est une société qui prépare les
populismes par la désespérance et par la
crainte de l'autre et donc nous avons
besoin de lutter contre cette ambiance
du chaos cette ambiance de la
disparition ce que je vous décris c'est
l'inverse de ce en quoi cette famille de
penser croit profondément depuis presque
100 ans et la création du parti
démocrate populaire nous l'aurons
beaucoup dissoutaines c'est le refus de
cette idée dangereuse selon laquelle une
idéologie un appareil ou une
organisation sociale pour être plus
important que l'homme et donc face à ces
mots face à ces vertiges des temps qui
saisissent nos sociétés démocratiques et
notre monde le centre les humanistes le
Mouvement Démocrate avons une
responsabilité particulière immense et
une histoire qui nous oblige et doit
plus que jamais nous conforter dans le
chemin que nous avons à emprunter
d'abord pour dire que notre ADN c'est
l'humanisme qui nous entraîne à refuser
les dogmes qui nous invitent et nous
donne la capacité à construire des
compromis et à les construire autour des
idées et de nourrir le débat politique
le pays a plus que jamais besoin des
artisans
des réconciliations impossibles que nous
sommes comme le disait Marc Sangnier les
seuls capables à mener et je sais je
sens qu'il peut s'agir de l'attente des
Français qui sortent sans doute pas
seulement comme les parlementaires cher
Jean-Paul et chirurgie un peu fatigué de
cette année de débat parfois beaucoup
plus vins qu'utilisent aux gens et je
suis assez frappé de voir d'ailleurs à
quel point l'écho a été positif aux
initiatives qui ont été prises par le
Président de la République décédé de
dire et si simplement on se parlait dans
ce pays et je pense que les Français
sont là d'un débat qui soit 20 et donc
nous devons être les artisans me
semble-t-il de ce débat et parce que
nous sommes
des tenants du respect de la tolérance
nous devons être les artisans
inlassables les fantassins déterminés de
la paix civile et donc nous tenus
résolument écartés des mots que
j'évoquais il y a quelques minutes sinon
nous seraurions apporté pour les autres
par les autres
notre deuxième ADN c'est de penser notre
pays dans son espace et dans son
environnement et donc de se penser chers
terrible ton en européen c'est aussi sur
cela que notre famille politique s'est
construite et j'ai une pensée à la fois
pour nos parlementaires et puis pour le
combat que mené Marielle pendant des
années sur ce débat européen et je suis
sûr qu'elle viendrait nous dire
aujourd'hui à quel point c'est à nouveau
un enjeu important et même ceux qui nous
expliquaient à longueur de journée que
tous les mots devenaient de l'Europe
sont aujourd'hui moins à l'aise pour le
faire quand ils voient que c'est dans
l'espace européen sur les sujets
climatiques sur les sujets migratoires
sur les sujets géopolitiques sur les
sujets de défense sur les sujets
d'autonomie stratégiques que nous avons
besoin de l'Europe et nous devons me
semble-t-il le porter notre ADN est
aussi et enfin
notre ADN aussi enfin et j'en termine
ainsi c'est de savoir se rassembler de
savoir s'ouvrir c'est d'avoir un esprit
de conquête le temps est venu de le
faire encore davantage d'aller sur le
terrain comme la guimaude encore plus de
fédérer autour de nous ce que de ce que
nous sommes et de ce que nous pensons de
nous enrichir aussi des autres et pour
cela nous pouvons nous appuyer sur notre
force la force du Mouvement Démocrate
notre ADN c'est de savoir ce qu'est
l'épreuve je le disais au début de mon
Provost mon propos pardon les routes
parfois sont un peu escarpées mais il
faut être serein face à elle c'est
d'être certain de notre capacité à tenir
la distance et donc à entraîner les
autres et dans la perspective des
combats que nous aurons amenés je
voudrais vous dire ma reconnaissance et
ma confiance à vous les présidents des
mouvements et responsables des
mouvements à vous les adhérents de la
première heure à ceux qui nous ont
rejoint à ceux élus ou non qui donnent
de leur énergie
les combats que nous avons amenés ne
sont pas les combats habituels de
parties ils vont nécessiter encore plus
d'exigences encore plus d'altruisme ils
sont déco bas pour les générations
futures ils ne seront plus ceux
simplement de la conquête du pouvoir ni
de la compétition légitime ou des débats
d'idées ils sont les combats les plus
fondamentaux qui soient parce qu'ils
sont les combats de la liberté de
l'humanité et de notre rapport au monde
en 2024 nous avons rendez-vous avec
notre histoire mais une fois de plus
pour ce qui est notre histoire de notre
famille politique une fois de plus nous
avons rendez-vous tout court avec
l'histoire et je nous souhaite en 2024
cher Thierry Breton cher François d'être
une nouvelle fois au rendez-vous de
l'Histoire celle de la famille
defanterie s'essaye de la famille des
humanistes merci à toutes et à tous
[Applaudissements]